The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Welcome
back, and today I'm
going to do for you three
problems all related
to driven harmonic oscillators.
Now one of the
things you'll notice
as I'm doing these
problems, that it seems
I'm doing the same thing
over and over again.
You may have also noticed
that in the other problems
I did earlier for you
in harmonic oscillators,
et cetera.
So at this stage, I have to
remind you about something.
This is no accident
that it is like that.
It's to do with the
scientific method,
and I would want to
briefly remind you
about how we are
solving problems.
Here is a diagram of
a generic problem.
What does it consists of?
A typical problem is we are
told of a physical situation
in words, ordinary language.
And in ordinary language, we
are asked questions about given
that physical
situation, what will
happen as a function of time?
What kind of emotion it
has, questions of that kind.
What problem solving is,
doing the scientific method,
is the following.
The first thing we have to do
is, by studying this situation
and using the laws
of nature, describing
the physical situation in terms
of mathematical equations.
This is always possible.
So starting with as I
say this description,
using laws of nature, we
end up with a description
in terms of
mathematical equations.
The next thing we
do is, we now forget
that this has anything
to do with physics.
We have a set of
mathematical equations,
which we have to solve.
This is mathematics.
We use mathematics to
solve this problem.
All right?
Once we have found the solution
to this mathematical equation,
there's only one thing
left, we identify the answer
with the questions
posed in the problem.
So understanding
of physics comes
in this step, which I call
step 1, and in the last one.
The middle one, step
2, is pure mathematics.
Now, it so happens that if
you take all driven harmonic
oscillators, the mathematics
that you end up with
is identical.
In other words, if I look at
the description of the problem
in mathematical terms, I cannot
tell you which problem that
description belongs.
That's a generic description
of many, many, many situations.
Today I'll take three of them,
but all three situations,
all three problems--
although to you, they
may look completely different--
after I've translated them
in terms of mathematical
equations, are identical.
And so it's not surprising
that from here on when we then
try to solve them, et cetera,
we are doing the same problem,
or at least it appears so.
Having said that,
let's immediately
dive in and take
one of the problems.
So the first problem
I'm going to consider
is an idealized-driven
RLC circuit.
Why do I see idealized?
Because as I've
mentioned before,
in real life situations,
things extremely complicated,
and if you take
everything into account,
it will take you
essentially forever
to get an exact solution.
But we're often not most
of the time not interested
in the very exact one.
So we simplify a
physical situation
to the bear essential parts
and solve that problem.
So this is a problem where
you have a circuit consisting
all a capacitance,
inductance, and a resistance,
in series, which is driven by
an alternating voltage source V0
cosine omega t.
Before time t equals 0, I'm
assuming the circuit is open.
In other words, there
is no charges anywhere,
no current flowing.
At t equals 0, we
close the circuit
so the charge on the
capacitor t equals 0, is 0.
The current flowing
in the circuit is 0.
All right?
And the question
we want to answer
is, what will the current be
in the circuit at some time t
a specific one, in 17 seconds
or whatever, some specific time.
Since this is
completely specified,
I can predict what will happen.
That's what it means in this
case solving this problem.
So let's do it.
So we are now entering step 1.
We're going to take
the physical situation
and convert it to a description
in terms of mathematics.
This is the conceptually
hardest step of any problem.
It is the one where you need
to understand the physics.
It may not necessarily be
the hardest or the longest.
Often the solution
of the equations
are incredibly tedious and
long and take all your time.
But they are
routine mathematics.
Here you've got to
conceptualize what's going on
and translate it as I say to
the language of mathematics.
So in the case of I've
had have to define
coordinates for this problem.
So what I have is, I'll assume
that at some instant of time
that in this
circuit, it's closed
because it's past
equal to 0, there
is a current I flowing that
on this capacitor on the left
there is plus charge
Q and minus charge
Q on the right side
that is this inductance.
And over here, we have an
alternating potential applied.
Now I have to be very specific
at any instant of time which
side is positive and negative.
I'll assume that t equals 0.
It's 0 over here,
and at this point
here, it's plus
V0 cosine omega t.
So these are the
coordinates of this problem.
And now what drives the current?
What decides what happens here?
What are the law of
natures applicable?
In this case, are the Maxwell's
equations or to be specific,
the Faraday equation.
All right?
One more thing I should add
that I is a current here flowing
charge by conservation
of charge.
It's law of physics.
The current at the
instant of time,
will be equal to the rate
of change of the charge.
So at the instant time,
I is, in my language,
Q with a dot on top of it.
This is plus because
of the way in which I
define my coordinates.
Beware if you by
mistake say suppose
I define my coordinates this
being minus and this plus,
then this equation
would be a minus here,
conservation of charge.
But with the way I've
defined these coordinates,
this is plus.
So that's one.
Next I said what
the law of nature
which governs the
motion of the charges
is the Faraday's
law, which states
that if I take the line
integral of the electric field
around a closed
loop, that's this,
it equals to minus
the rate of change
of total magnetic flux
linking this circuit,
going through this circuit.
Now, you know that the
magnetic flux through a circuit
is equal to the current
times the self-inductance
of that circuit or the total
inductance in that circuit.
So taking this law of
nature, this law of nature,
I can now translate
this into mathematics,
and that's what I'm going to do.
So first I'm going to take
the line integral of E dl
around this circuit.
If I go around
from here to here,
this is positive
relative to this point,
so the electric field
from here to here
will be in this direction, and
so the line integral of E dl
along here will be minus, and
by definition of a voltage,
it will be just minus
the voltage drop
across here, which
is V0 cosine omega t.
So this is minus
V0 cosine omega t.
I continue going around.
From here to here, the electric
field is in this direction.
And so that will be
the integral V dl
is Q over C, that's from the
definition of a capacitance,
of course.
Then as we go around in
these idealized diagrams,
all wires have 0 resistance and
therefore there cannot be field
in them.
That's why there's no
contribution to this
from the field inside the wires.
I continue.
This inductance is
just coiled wire,
so there's still no contribution
to this in the L. I continue.
Here I know there is a current
flowing like this means
the reason the electric
field in this direction
and once again knowing the
definition of our Ohms law,
I get that the integral of
the electric fields from here
to here is I times R.
So this is this
quantity, the integral
of the electric field
around this closed loop.
That must equal by Faraday's
law to minus the rate of change
of magnetic flux,
which is minus L dI dt.
We're almost finished.
Now we do algebra.
We're playing around.
I can rewrite this like this
knowing that the current is
the rate of change of Q, and
the rate of change of current
is the second derivative.
So this is just
straightforward algebra.
Now, I'm going to rewrite
just moving terms around
to make it look in
the way I prefer.
And so I've rewritten this
equation now in this form.
And now, I will just
redefine some constants
so that I recognize
the equation better.
So I will define R over
L by a constant gamma.
And I will define 1 over LC by
the constant omega 0 squared.
And I define V0 L
by the constant f.
And so this equation
rewritten looks like that.
Eureka.
This is an equation I've
seen millions of times,
and I know how to solve it.
So what we've done is, we've
taken this physical situation,
translated it into a
mathematical equation.
This is the equation
of motion, this just
defines the constants, and this
is the boundary conditions.
It tells us that in
our particular problem,
we switch that
circuit at t equals 0.
At that time, what
was the condition
of the current and charge?
So Q at 0 we said was 0.
Q dot at 0 was 0.
This completely, mathematically
defines that problem.
This is the mathematical
description of this problem.
From now on, I don't
have to even remember
that this has anything
to do with physics.
This is now a problem
in mathematics.
What is the solution
of this equation
satisfying these
boundary conditions?
We'll do that later.
I'm now going to immediately
go to the next problem.
See in each case,
I've done the physics.
This is the end of the
physics in essence.
From now on, I just
have to do mathematics.
So let me take the next
problem, a different one.
It seems completely different.
Here we were dealing with
charges, currents, circuits, et
cetera, and now I'm going
to look at the physical one.
I could even bring you
a model of that problem.
What I'm going to consider
here is an ideal pendulum,
simple pendulum, ideal, which
is a heavy mass, considered
to be a point mass, a
string, which is considered
to be always taught
but yet massless.
So it's an ideal pendulum.
What I have here is an
approximation to an ideal one,
and if I understand
what the ideal one does,
this in reality, will you do
something pretty close to it.
And so what I'm
going to consider,
I am going to be oscillating
my hand backwards and forwards
sinusoidally starting this
at some definite time,
and I'll try to predict
the motion of this.
And notice I can make all
sorts of motion out of this.
If I do it slowly, look,
my hand and the ball
are going in the same direction.
If I go fast, they're going
in opposite direction.
And the way this is
oscillating is different,
depends on how I am moving
my hand backward and forward.
So let me tell you
very precisely what is
this idealized situation which
I am trying to solve and predict
what will happen.
So I have this ideal pendulum.
It has a length, L, mass, m.
It's in the vertical plane.
Gravity is down there.
At one end of the string,
I will be moving my hand
in perfect sinusoidal fashion.
It will have an amplitude of
x0 and angular frequency omega,
so it's x0 sine omega t.
I am making the
following assumptions,
that's why it's idealized.
I'm assuming it's
a massless string.
I'm assuming it's always taught.
I'm going to assume that it's
all making small oscillations
so that if in any
calculation, I can take a sine
to be an angle to be
equal to the angle.
Furthermore I'm going to assume
that there is a bit of drag,
there is friction,
and I will assume
that the frictional
force on this that mass
is proportional to the
velocity, and the constant
of that velocity is B. Now
you ask me, why choose that?
Well, the simple
answer is, I want
to find this situation
when I know I can solve it.
And I know how to
solve this problem
if it's proportional
to velocity.
If it's something
more complicated,
then the equation may
be correct at the end,
but I will not be able to
just like that on the board,
solve it for you.
I could do it numerically,
use a computer, et cetera,
but at the same time, I know
that if I have something which
is very close to being what
the actual situation is,
the prediction of the real world
compared to this idealized one
will not be very different.
Qualitatively, I will
get a good understanding
of what's going on.
So this is the assumption,
and what is the question?
What do I want to predict?
I want to now take a
very specific situation.
I want to take a situation
that at t equals 0 initially,
the mass is stationary, and
it's exactly below my hand,
but my hand is not
stationary, it's moving.
So I am moving this backwards
and forwards sinusoidally,
all right?
And in the instant, when
my hand is over the ball,
I let go of the ball and
then I continue moving it.
So I have specified this exactly
what this ball is doing at t
equals 0, what my
hand is doing, and I
want to predict what will happen
at some arbitrary later time.
So my question is
what will happen,
and this time to make it a
little more interesting also,
I want to know in qualitative
terms what kind of motion
will it have if I move
this slowly and quickly
and check against
reality at the end.
And [? originally ?]
I could tell you
that things are different
when I'm doing it slowly.
As I told you before,
if I do this slowly
like this, my hand and the ball
going in the same direction.
If I go fast, I can make them
go in opposite directions.
All that should
come out of this.
So the part of the question
is to qualitatively understand
this phenomenon.
So that's my problem number 2.
The third problem
that I'm going to do.
Sorry.
I haven't done it.
That's what I want to
do, and I have to do it.
I wanted to get the exact things
over quicker, but no such luck.
Now, I'm going to
solve this problem.
So back again.
Look at that diagram and
what's the first thing to do.
Step 1 use the laws of nature
to restate this problem
in terms of math and
language of mathematics.
That's what we have to do.
All right.
Let's go a little fast.
So I have to define
some coordinate system
so I redraw my
picture and now I'm
going to tell you that I'll take
some vertical stationary axis
here, and I'll say it
instant t, this mass
is at some position, y.
My hand holding
here is at position
is at x0 sine omega t, time t.
Fine.
That this string is taught.
I said the assumption
is it's massless
so therefore it
has to be taught.
That's one of the reasons why
we have to make a massless.
If it wasn't massless, it could
start getting kinks and I'll be
doing this, but the
massless one cannot,
and that's a good question for
you to think why that statement
is correct.
It's nontrivial.
All right.
Then at some instant of time,
this angle I'll called theta.
And now this is a
problem in dynamics.
Basically, I can draw my free
body diagram, a force diagram.
I have this force, mass m.
What forces are acting on it?
Well, there is gravity
pulling it down, the force mg.
There is a frictional
force which
we assume will be
proportional to the velocity,
so this is the
frictional force which
will be minus b
times the velocity.
There will be a tension
in this string pulling it
in that direction.
And the sum of forces, by
Newton's laws of motion,
will give rise to
the acceleration.
The acceleration
will be net force
divided by C inertia, the
system which is the mass.
We have now experience.
I'm not going to go slowly.
I'll immediately take
the components of forces.
First let me consider
vertical motion.
I told you the angle is small.
If I make the angle
sufficiently small
and that ball is oscillating,
it is not moving up and down.
The distance is tiny
insignificant in this problem.
So I can ignore the
vertical motion.
So the vertical
acceleration is 0.
The net vertical force
here is the component
of t in the up direction
which is t cosine
theta minus the gravity
down, and that's
equal to 0, no acceleration.
Therefore t is mg.
T is the tension in this string.
How about horizontal?
For horizontal motion, I
have the horizontal component
of this tension here
which is t sine theta.
This is theta, so t sine theta
is the horizontal component.
Now, this is moving
here, therefore,
there will be a frictional
force proportional to that.
So that's minus, this is
the velocity, times b,
so this is the frictional force.
It's always minus, it's
always in opposition
to the actual velocity.
And that by Newton's
law is equal to mass
times the horizontal
acceleration.
Beware of my symbols.
This whole problem for me
is really in one dimension.
So I called x the horizontal
motion of my hand,
and I'm calling y the
horizontal motion of the mass.
This has nothing to do
with x, y, z, one being
up and the other horizontal.
It's all horizontal.
I had a choice.
I could have called
this x1 and this x2.
I chose to call them x and y.
You're smart enough to
figure the difference,
to follow that kind
of terminology.
So now I can rewrite this.
I know what sine theta is
if I look at this diagram.
Sine theta is simply
equal to the distance.
It's x minus y.
It's sine theta.
This angle equals, I
should draw this here.
This angle equals that
one, so sine theta
is this distance
divided by that length,
and this distance
is x minus y over l.
So this is sine theta
minus by equals this.
Quickly, I can play
with the algebra,
and I end up with this equation.
And lo and behold,
Eureka, once again I
get almost the same equation.
I purposely chose it so it
didn't come out exactly right.
Before I ended up
with a cosine, now I
have ended up with a sine.
Intention.
All right.
So to show that something which
seems different often is not.
So rewriting this in terms
of constant, which I like,
I do the same as before.
I define this b over m as
gamma, this g over l as omega
squared, this thing
here as f, and I end up
with this equation where
the constants are here
and the initial conditions
are that the position
of this mass at time 0 is 0,
and that the velocity was 0.
You remember I considered
the mass being stationary.
This is now a set of
mathematical equations.
I have described this problem
in terms of mathematics.
From now on, I can
forget that this
has anything to do
with that problem.
I have to solve now a
mathematical problem.
Finally.
One more.
Let me consider
one more problem,
and once we've done all
three, at least part
of step 1 of all three we'll go
and solve them all in one go.
And I repeat what I've done
here I've done all the physics.
This is the part which
causes most difficulty,
needs most understanding of the
physical situation, et cetera.
It may or may not
take a very long time.
The next step is
routine mathematics,
which can be the part which
takes you a whole night solving
because you make
algebraic errors,
and you sweat and you
go back, et cetera.
That's the part you may be
cursing when you're doing it,
but it is routine from then on.
It doesn't need an
understanding of the physics
of the situation, and what I'm
trying to help you understand
is physics, not
mathematics at this stage.
So let's take another
problem, which
again, seems
completely different.
All right.
Here it's a seismograph,
in other words,
a device for detecting
tremors of the Earth.
And the following would work.
Take attached to
the floor a spring.
Put the mass, m, on it,
and just look at the mass
how it's behaving.
If the Earth starts
oscillating, an earthquake,
the mass will oscillate.
How much it oscillates
will give you
a measure of how badly
the Earth is oscillating.
So I'm going to here do
an idealized seismograph.
I will model it by a mass, m,
sitting on top of a massless,
ideal spring, which is
attached to the floor.
I will idealize the
earthquake and saying
it's oscillating with
a single frequency
with a single amplitude.
The floor is oscillating by
an amplitude y0 sine omega t.
It's oscillating.
So my assumptions are this
spring is ideal massless.
The base, Hooke's law,
that's the ideal part.
I will again assume that
there is a damping, which
will be proportional to the
velocity, for the same reasons
as I took the other one to
be proportional to velocity.
And the question
this time will be
not to predict where that mass
is at a given interval of time,
but the question is, for
what values of the mass
and the spring
constant, k, will I
get the most
sensitive instrument?
So this seems
completely different
and the question seems different
the other ones et cetera,
but as you will see
it all boils down
to one and the same question.
So how do we do this?
So now let me come
down to step 1,
understanding the
situation, the problem
in terms of mathematics.
All right.
So I've re-drawn
here the situation.
This is my coordinate
system of the problem.
The surface of the floor,
I'll assume it's here.
It's moving.
It is not a good
reference place.
It's moving.
All right.
So it's here.
The mass, m, is there
attached to the spring
of natural length, l0,
spring constant, k.
There is the mass sitting on it.
Now, we've got to take a
coordinate system which
isn't moving.
Got to have an inertial one.
The surface of the Earth
is no good for this.
It's vibrating.
So the best thing we
have are the fixed stars.
So let's take the fixed
stars as a reference.
So this is a height
in that room, which
is fixed in position
relative to the fixed stars.
Now, the surface of the Earth
can be moving relative to that,
and I am making the assumption
it's moving sinusoidally
with amplitude y0.
So this is the floor, position
of the floor at time, t.
The mass relative to this,
which I defined as my y equal 0,
is at position y of m.
So this now is again
a problem in dynamics,
a mass with forces acting on
it, what is the acceleration,
and what is the solution
of the dynamic equation,
the equation of motion.
So the force diagram
or free body diagram
is a point mass, m, with a
force fg due to gravity on it,
a force, f, due to the
spring acting on it,
and I forgot to put this.
Of course, there will be a
force here due to friction
acting on it.
This is probably not a
good place to draw it.
Let me draw it so it
doesn't confuse you.
I'll draw it next
to this, friction.
So these are in same
direction et cetera.
All right.
So now let's use
Newton's laws of motion,
f equals ma, and
relate the forces
to the resulting acceleration.
So first of all what is
the net up-going force?
I'm taking a coordinate system
where this is a one dimensional
problem, so I don't
have to use vectors.
I'll consider just
the magnitude.
My positive force is upwards.
So at any instant
of time, this mass
will have a force due to the
spring and it will depend.
If this spring is compressed,
the force will be up.
If it's elongated, stretched,
the force will be down.
And the magnitude would be
k times the change of length
from the natural length,
so the upward force
will be the difference
between those two subtracted
from the natural length.
So k times the natural length
minus this quantity, which
is the difference
between this and this,
which therefore this is how
much the string is compressed,
how much is compressed
and is forced upwards.
If this is a positive
number, it's a negative one,
it's stretched, it's
putting it down.
So this is the force
up due to the spring,
this is the force
down due to gravity,
and this is the force in
opposition to the velocity.
I don't know whether
it's up or down.
It depends which way it's
moving due to the friction.
This is the net
force, and that's
got to be equal to the
inertia of the system, which
is the mass times the
acceleration of it
to the upward direction.
And I told you this spring
is massless, et cetera,
so I don't have to
take into account
the motion of the spring.
And that's why I have to
take an idealized situation.
Back now to algebra.
From here, I manipulate
this, and I end up
with this equation.
You can do the same,
and I've replaced
for example, the motion of
the floor by y0 sine omega t,
et cetera, from here.
And at first I say, oh, hell.
This looks different than the
one equation I've seen before.
But then I don't have to be an
Einstein to realize, hold on.
If I redefine this as my
variable, in other words,
if I take define y as ym plus mg
over k minus l0, this quantity,
the rate of change of y is
the rate of change of ym
because these are constants,
and the second derivative of y
is the second derivative
of this, is a constant.
And therefore, I can
rewrite the equation
as well y double dot plus
gamma y dot plus omega 0
squared y is equal to a
constant and sine omega t
where these constants are
written here from this equation
and I redefine my variable.
And now, Eureka, I'm back
again to the same problem.
So once, again, what we've done.
We've taken a physical situation
and a physical question
from our understanding
of the laws of nature
which apply to that situation.
We have translated it to
a problem in mathematics.
And here it is.
That's the problem,
and I can now,
at least for the
next few minutes,
forget that this is
physics, treat it
as a problem in mathematics.
And that's what I'll do
it now, but first I've
got to make some
room for myself.
I have nowhere to write, so
I have to erase some things,
and we'll continue
in a few minutes.
All right.
We've erased the boards, and
we can therefore continue.
Let me remind you
what we have shown
is we've taken three completely
different systems, described
them in terms of mathematics.
The three systems with
an electrical circuit,
an RLC circuit.
We took a pendulum, driven on
a pendulum, and a seismograph.
Each one of these ended up
with almost identical equation.
In fact, the only
difference is one of them
ended up with a cosine here,
the other two with a sine.
I will comment about
that in a second.
We are now, forgetting
about the physics,
we are now in the
world of mathematics.
These equations of
motion need to be
solved if we are to
predict what will
happen in those situations.
Now, there are many ways of
solving differential equations.
It is not my job
to teach you how
to solve differential equations.
For an example, you can go
to the lectures of Professor
Walter Lewin, and
he does illustrate
how one can solve these
using complex amplitudes.
I am satisfied if I
find the solutions.
I don't care how.
I can take them
from what he did,
I can take them from a book
of mathematics, et cetera,
and what you will
find is that if you
have a generic second
ordered differential
equation of this
form, it has solution
which looks like this, the
most general solution that
looks like that.
There is no other solution
in the universe which
is not represented
by this equation.
You can manipulate it,
make it look different,
but it will boil down
to this equation.
How do I know that?
Because of something
I mentioned earlier,
the so-called
uniqueness theorem.
This is a second order
differential equation.
This equation satisfies it.
Try it, take it,
differentiate it twice this,
et cetera, u
[? dissatisfied. ?] Furthermore,
it has two arbitrary constants.
This C can be anything and
this phi can be anything.
They are arbitrary.
Everything else in this equation
is completely determined.
For example, a of
omega depends on omega.
This amplitude, a,
is equal to f divided
by the square root of omega
0 squared minus omega squared
0 squared plus gamma
omega 0 squared.
All these constants--
omega, gamma, f, omega 0--
are known in each
of the problems.
Let me just as an example
take the last problem we
did When we derived
the equation of motion,
we furthermore knew exactly
what each one of those constants
meant.
They are known, so I don't
need to solve for them.
So a of omega is this quantity.
The delta, the phase there
is, again, a known quantity.
The time of delta is this.
It is only under
these conditions
that this satisfies
that equation.
And find the omega prime here
also is a known quantity.
Nothing here is unknown.
The only unknowns are
the C, and the phi,
and they are
arbitrary constants.
This works for any value
of C and any value of phi.
Now, one more comment.
These look equations.
One looks like a
cosine theta sine.
If you stop and
think for a second,
they're actually one
and the same equation
where you've
redefined what is t 0.
So by just changing the phase
of this, you'll get to this.
You've changed it by 90 degrees.
Just redefine what
t0 is, your clock,
and you'll get
from this to that.
So if this equation
I've written here
is a solution to
the cosine part,
if my driver has this
phase, in other words,
sine omega t, then the answer
will be displaced with respect
to this one by that same thing.
Instead of having a cosine
here, you have a sign.
So from my perspective, these
two are identical equations,
and the solution for
them is identical.
It's also worth looking at what
the mathematics of this looks
like.
What this looks like is the
solution to these equations
is some function with a certain
amplitude, which is oscillatory
with the same frequency
as the driver.
So this is just an
oscillatory function.
It's got a different
phase to that.
They lag will lead
it, different phase,
but it's just constant
amplitude oscillatory function.
Added to it is another
oscillatory function
with a slightly
different frequency,
but which with time decays,
because of this e to the minus
gamma over 2t.
And by the way, one more
thing I should just emphasize.
In writing this solution,
I've made the assumption
that this oscillator does oscil.
You're driving something
which oscillates and is
an overdamped
system in which case
this term here would be
different and not interesting
when normally you wouldn't drive
things and be interested in how
it responds if it's
incredibly damped system.
So I am making the
assumption that this
is an underdamped system, which
means that this quantity here
is greater than
this quantity here.
And if you're having
difficulty with this part,
I urge you to review what
happens with just not driven
oscillators under conditions
of being underdamped
or overdamped.
That's the same physics.
So we found the most
general solution.
This solution must apply to
every problem we've done.
So I'll now take one of them.
For example, let's
consider this problem.
We did this.
We have an RLC circuit.
They are an equation of motion.
From here, I can
immediately write
what is the solution of this.
As a function of
time, the charge Q
will be equal to-- just look
at that-- a of omega times
cosine omega t minus delta-- I'm
just copying from over there--
plus some arbitrary constant
e to the minus gamma over 2t.
And here we have a cosine, so I
took the cosine here, and here
is cosine of omega prime t
plus this arbitrary phase phi.
So this is a general
equation, which
satisfies that one at all times.
And I'm repeating myself.
This, you know, it will
be given by A of omega
will be equal to
f, and what is f?
f is v0 over L-- I just
read it off there-- divided
by square root of
omega 0 squared,
which is 1 over LC
minus omega squared
That's just the frequencies with
which the voltage is driving
there all squared
plus gamma omega.
Gamma is R over L
omega all squared.
And time delta is
equal to gamma omega.
Gamma is R over L
divided by omega 0
squared, which is 1 over
LC minus omega squared.
So far we know everything
except the C and the phi.
The question actually
was, I've now erased,
it but the question was
what is the current flowing?
And the current
flowing I of t, is
equal to dq dt with
the way we define
the signs with a part plus here,
which is equal to Q dot, which
I can get from this by
differentiating this equation,
and I get differentiate
this minus omega
A of omega sine of
omega t minus delta.
Go to differentiate
this, I get minus gamma
over 2 Ce to the minus gamma
over 2t times cosine omega
prime t plus phi.
So I've differentiated
this times that.
Now I've got to take
this differentiated
by that, which minus Ce e to
the minus gamma over 2t times
omega prime times sine
omega prime t plus phi.
Sorry.
That's so.
So and again, we
know every quantity
here except for C and phi.
Those are unknowns.
So this would be the
answer to my question
if I knew C and phi,
then everything is known.
Then I could
predict exactly what
would happen with
any instant of time.
How do I find those two?
This is where the boundary
conditions come in.
That's why you need
at least two boundary
conditions or
initial conditions,
two facts about this system
to be able to determine
those constants,
and we're always
in the physical
situation of this kind,
you will have two
bits of information.
For example, in this
case, I told you
that we will assume
that t equals
0 the charge and
the capacitance is 0
and the current in
the circuit is 0.
I could have told you
something else at the beginning
and the answer
would be different.
All right.
And the thing that
would be different
would be those constants.
So how do we do it?
Simply by taking this equation
and writing it at the time t
equals 0.
So at t equals 0, we
know what Q of 0 is,
and we know what Q dot of 0 is.
So I take this
equation, set t to 0,
and write down this equal to 0.
Sorry.
I take this equation,
the Q. This one set
t to 0 and write 0 equals
that with t equals 0.
I write another
equation from here.
At t equals 0, Q dot is 0, so
I take this one, set t to 0,
and write another equation.
I will end up with two
algebraic equations
with two unknowns
which you can solve.
Now remember I told you,
the hard part conceptually
is getting the equations
of motion right.
But the slog, the
sweat, and a hard labor
is getting this solution
right, and I'm not
going to go here now and
embarrass myself making error
after algebraic error
solving those equations.
I know you can solve them
if you keep your cool
and follow all the
constants, et cetera.
You take these two algebraic
equations, solve them,
you come out with a value for C
and a value for the phase phi,
and then I have
the final answer.
I then have this equation I
of t and Q of t for any T.
And so I can predict at
any time with this will do.
End of story.
Now, let me take another case
and to look at this one here,
and I'll go a little faster.
This is the mathematical
description of the pendulum.
So again, I'll take
this, initially I'll
do the same as I did before, so
I will write that y at time t
is equal to-- and I have
to once again just follow
the thing-- it's f, which
is gx over L divided
by the square root
of omega squared,
which is g over L minus omega
squared all squared plus gamma,
which is b over m this time
gamma omega all squared.
So times.
Now, here I have a
sign so it's going
to be the sine omega
t minus delta plus--
and to save time, not
rewrite it, the full thing,
but I'll start at the beginning.
There's the Ce to the
minus gamma over 2t
here at cosine et cetera.
So what we see
here as before, we
can get what this mass will
do as a function of time,
and as before, I don't want
to just go around and around
repeating the thing is.
In order to solve, everything
here is known except the C
and this phase here-- maybe I
should at least write that in.
That is omega prime t plus phi.
And in principle,
this and that you
can get, again, by using
the initial conditions.
I don't want to focus on that.
In this case, I want to
focus what the problem said.
What it said it
was, discuss what
you would expect the
motion to be for that.
In other words, when
we took this special,
we took this and took in
given initial conditions
and let's go.
This will describe what goes on.
And let's look at this solution.
What we see is that there
are two terms here as before.
This is an oscillation of the
same frequency as a driver.
So other words, that
term is something
which has this moving with
the same frequency as my hand.
This is a slightly
different frequency,
which is exponentially decaying.
When you add two
oscillating functions,
you've learned from Professor
Walter Lewin's class,
you get beats.
So at first when this is
large, these two wave motions,
these oscillatory
motions will beat
minutes one against
the other and you
will get some kind
of a crazy motion.
You can't make sense of it.
As a function of time, as t
becomes bigger and bigger,
this exponential kills this
term, and after a long time,
you'll end up with
only this term, which
is simple sinusoidal motion.
Try it for yourself.
If I start any
old way and I then
move with a given
frequency, you'll
find this has a constant
frequency, some amplitude given
by this, and it continues
doing this forever
consistent with it.
But there is another
interesting feature,
which I would like
you to focus on.
If the friction is very
small, like this, this
will have very little
damping, after a long time,
this has gone and this
term I can neglect.
And what I see
here is that this,
the amplitude of the
oscillations of this not only
depends on the amplitude-- and
again, I notice the time here;
this is the node quantity
here-- not only depends
on the amplitude of how
far my head is moving,
but it depends critically
on the difference between g
over l and omega squared.
This, if you remember from
the simple pendulum-- that's
this omega 0 squared--
gives the frequency
of oscillation of a free
pendulum of this length.
So what happens depends
critically how different
and of which magnitude
is between the frequency
of oscillation of
my hand compared
to the natural frequency
of oscillation.
If-- and here I
won't do the algebra.
I'll let you do this
as an exercise-- play
for yourself changing
the value of this making
it bigger than that
or smaller than that.
And what you will find is that
the motion of that and sorry,
there's one more
thing I should have
said I didn't, and let
me just say it now.
There is also this question
of this phase delta,
tan delta is equal
to gamma omega
over omega 0 squared
minus omega squared.
So the sine of delta depends on
whether it's bigger or smaller.
Play for yourself
changing this value.
See what happens to
the amplitude here
and what happens to this
phase, and what you'll see
is that if I go slowly,
the phase is such
that the two go
in phase together
if my oscillating
frequency is lower
than the natural frequency
of oscillation of this,
while if I go faster, in
other words, higher frequency,
this becomes a negative
and the phase gets out
of phase by 180
degrees, the two.
Furthermore, if you
look at this amplitude,
you can completely understand
it in the following way.
Imagine that I had this
string and I move it slowly.
I'm moving this slowly,
and what you'll see
is it's going in phase with
that, and the angle of this
will be such that
this string appears
to be the continuation
of a single string, which
has a longer length.
And the string with the longer
length has a lower frequency.
So if I move here with
the lower frequency
than the natural
frequency, this will
appear to be part of a string
which has just the right length
to give me the
frequency of my hand.
While if I move with
the higher frequency,
what the string
will do is do this.
Here is my hand moving
backwards and forwards.
There is the mass,
and the mass is
moving backwards and forwards.
All right.
This string is
oscillating as if it
was a free string
of a shorter length.
I urge you as an exercise,
to play with the numbers
here and consider
these two cases.
It is a beautiful,
educational tool
to understand why if you
have a driven system,
response can be in
phase or out of phase
depending on the relative
frequency you're driving
the system compared to
the natural frequency
of oscillation of
the oscillator.
And this example
brings everything out.
Take this example,
consider very little
damping so that you can do
the calculations easily.
See what's the
relative amplitude
of the driver compared
to the response
and what's the relative
phase of the driver compared
to the response, and all
this characteristics you'll
see which you can play for
yourselves with a little model.
I really urge you to do that.
Finally today, I
will just comment.
You see we're now in
a world of repeating.
We're doing the same
thing over and over again.
I would just like to comment
about the seismograph.
Once again, this is an
equation of this form.
It's the sine version.
So this is the solution
to it with a sine,
and the question is,
in this case was,
what the value of k over
m makes it most sensitive?
That's equivalent to
asking the question,
after a long time--
this earthquake
has lasted a long time--
this so-called transient,
this term dies away.
So this we can forget.
This is the response of the
mass to the earthquake which
we assumed it's a uniform
frequency, sinusoidal driver.
And so the question is, what is
the amplitude of the response?
How big is this term?
This term we know how
big it is, and if you
look at this function, you see
that this amplitude depends
on omega, on the driver.
Now let's assume the
damping is not very big.
This will be small
compared to that.
And so if you want
a big response,
you want this quantity
to be very small
so that f divided by
this is a big number.
When will this be small?
When these two are almost equal.
So what you want, if you want
to have an instrument which
is very sensitive, you want to
study so the dominant frequency
of oscillations of
earthquakes in your area
and adjust the natural frequency
of oscillation close to that.
And the natural frequency is
of course given by k over m.
So what matters is, it doesn't
matter what m is, what k is,
but what's the
ratio of k over m?
You want that to be close
to the natural frequency,
that the natural frequency of
this oscillator, that value
k over m, to be close to the
frequency of the oscillations
of the earth in the earthquake.
If this driver really
had a definite frequency,
I could solve this problem
to find the maximum.
If I plotted this as
a function of omega,
I would get a curve
something like this.
This is a function of
omega, the amplitude,
the response of that oscillator.
if you do that, you'll find
that if the natural frequency
of oscillation is
over here, the peak
is slightly at the
lower frequency
than the natural frequency
of oscillation omega 0.
And so you could do this
exactly by plotting it out
to find out what is the
optimum value of the frequency
that you want to adjust so
that you get the best response.
So much for driven oscillators.
We will now move to
couple oscillators,
and that we'll do next
time, some problems.
Thank you.